hi I'm Natalie hi Jude and we're here
doing the wire also complete interview
the only one of these I watched with
Michael Kay was doing it and every
answer is funny I should ask that
amazing alan arkin on the air was like
going what natalie portman but Natalie
Portman's
study psychology just to talk later I'm
gonna ask you about something what does
Natalie Portman oh do I pretend to be
other people I'm a female impersonator
what does Natalie Portman look like now
what do you think what oh boy
languages can natalie portman speak
English I I sort of Hebrew was my first
language deal with them said at the hub
at shitty locks looks Rebekah she'll see
my new movie please what does natalie
portman eat anything vegan and all the
time I'm eating all the time what did
Natalie from any invent anything you
know what though I'm not surprised
people thought you feel possibly an
inventor thank you that's so you're
small and I can imagine them sitting at
home going what if that exchange GPA
like a bandit something I should
take credit for something yeah oh wait
did come up with something the other day
have you ever had to fill two fish yes
Jewish food you have horseradish yes
that it's kind of the same thing as
wasabi right yeah
juicy no one's made it why don't they
make sushi so yeah no that might be like
a that's a kind of thumb invented that
you guys that's a Japanese Israeli kind
of fusion here
fusion align you man you heard it here
first
oh I don't like the starring of this is
Jude Law is Jude Law British yes I am
British watch there's only go really
fast is Jude Law Captain Marvel no I'm
not Bree Larson he's Captain Marvel
could make sure the Marvel please I'm
going to shoot me no I can say that is
Jude Law
left-handed no see the interest income
in Google about yeah I'm not issued let
a spaceman that means Tottenham Hotspur
yes I am thank you for traveling all my
life is Jude Law related to Ella Tom
Percival because I'm British all Brits
are related way back is Jude Law the
voice of Jarvis in Iron Man no that's
Paul Bettany who goes on to play the
embodiment of Jarvis vision Wow Wow did
next alright where is Natalie Portman
from I was born in Jerusalem
I grew up mainly in New York where did
Natalie Portman go to college I went to
Harvard tissue I did when was Natalie
Portman Oh born what a question
Oh Jerri I was born in 1981 I was born
in the 1900s when did Natalie Portman
become vegan seven years ago when I was
about to give birth to my child my first
child reading the book eating animals
highly recommend it
who is Natalie Portman friends with well
my closest friends are people you've
probably never heard of they're my
friends from school I have a few friends
from work work life California lives too
you got a lot of friends I have so many
friends I'm three friends I'm so lucky
I'm jealous you only have three friends
that's not true I've seen you you hope
I've seen you out I've seen you out and
about I know I got a lot of
acquaintances I'm getting nervous about
the does is it is Jude Law tattoos I do
I have just a couple of mice forums here
very small ones does tyou
nor speak Spanish no I don't but I think
they may be asking that because there's
a scene in the young Pope I learnt the
scene in Spanish because because Pope's
tend to speak multiple languages so I
learn Italian and Spanish for that for
the for the film but you speak Italian
now see okay
did Jude Law narrate Fargo no wish I had
I love that film oh yeah interesting
yeah how old is Jude Law's daughter well
I have three daughters I have an 18 year
old I have a 7 year old and I have a
four year old how old is Jude Law sons
22 and 16 how did you lord someone what
I know what I love about that is is
they're just pretty certain I am dead
and they want to know how there was a
period when all my parts ended it
brother gruesome me I've had my brains
bashed in I've been blown up oh I got
shot didn't your family members get
upset about it because I my family
members get very distressed I did make
the mistake of showing my son a I a
little bit too young and Wendy a gigolo
Joe gets sort of sucked off by giant
magnet and kind of by you assumed pulled
to pieces for scrap on its somewhat
affected him he was told he's forgiven
me
dogs natalie portman this is the dog
just Natalie Portman and sister mom and
only child doesn't highly Portman him
and Oscar damn right do you thank you
very much does Natalie Portman have
naturally curly hair yes I have a big
beautiful jewfro iron there's Natalie
Portman sing in Fox luxe yeah I do I
sing songs written and sung yeah
does Natalie Portman sing Natalie's rap
yes I do I do it
on YouTube you can check it out it's
awesome thank you what dude laughs what
that was July first movie shopping it
was called yeah many many many years ago
what is Jude Law and a semester abroad
about okay I'm a bit embarrassed about
this this is a song called Jude Law and
a semester abroad or something like that
not quite sure I think I listen to it
like once or twice years back when it
came out but I don't I don't quite know
what it's about so if anyone knows
please let me know what height is Jude
Law I wish I could say I was 6 foot one
but I'm not I'm a little shorter than
that on a good day I'm 6 foot on the bad
dome 5 11 and a half watts Jude Law's
real name okay this is a competetive
really this is an annoying annoying
truth my parents stupidly have this idea
to name me and my sister after they're
best friends
my sister my dad's best friend is David
and my sister's best friend is Andrea
but they never called us those names so
my middle name Jude is what my mum and
dad or everyone always calls her so my
name on my passport is David Jude
Hayworth the law hey with his my mom's
maiden name but no one's ever called me
David my everyone's called me too but I
get people always like oh you changed
your name to Jude because you're an
actor I did thanks mom and dad what did
you lure up to what colour of Jude Law's
eyes look they can't change colour bluey
green depends on what shirt you're
wearing colored well I hope you learned
something about us go see our movie box
lips yeah and thanks for watching
autocomplete